when I was a kid I thought jacking off
meant you were gay like I didn't know
that that meant that you just were a
regular person right and so I lived with
that until I was like until I was 18
years old you were jerking off thinking
you were gay though I thought I just
thought I must be gay I can't stop I
must be one of those weird gay guys
that's only attracted to women because I
don't I'm only jacking off the chicks
and I'm looking up with chicks I had sex
with a chick but I can't quit jacking
off and then we got into our fraternity
and they said something about jacking
off and I was like hold on you guys you
guys do that and they're like everyone
does it I was like where the [__] was
this open and honesty like where was
this my whole entire [__] life and
they call it jacking off with like a
name Jack no that's when they started
calling it rubbing one out oh everyone
rubs one out yeah and I was like rub was
one out they're like yeah you know and I
was like dude Eddie Bravo said they
people would just used to say play with
themselves yeah and it was totally
normal what you gonna what's going on
today man I'm probably gonna just you
know have you know have some cool lady
maybe play with myself or maybe you know
get a new harp or something dude I wish
that that it happened earlier from me
growing up because it was I really was
like I must be a pervert Yeah there must
be something wrong with me like I don't
think I ever really like at a certain
age you go I'm definitely straight I'm
I'm sleeping with I lost my virginity to
a chick all I want are chicks I remember
the first time I felt a chick up in the
bushes remember when you go back into
the bushes oh yeah and just make out and
just hold just play with their tit a
million different ways you're like I've
been waiting for this day my entire
[__] life oh my God oh my God oh my
God like oh dude I remember some girl
didn't want uh me to she was like so
nervous about like God I guess seeing us
touch each other whatever we're in a
sand trap on a golf course right yeah oh
[__] she was so nervous damn it she took
her [__] pants off and everything and
then like tried to cover as much of her
body as she could with [__] sand
right so then I don't even I'm still I'm
young dude I can get through some sand
for some crotch you know like this is
you know yeah this is [__] you know
I'm fired up you know what I'm saying
probably shoot semen through a [__]
wall of sand at that time as a girl hit
her vagina as a golfer would say she was
a fried egg
so then I'm just playing with this you
know touching this girl's crotch with
sand everywhere and it was it you know
it ended up kind of stopping the
scenario and she and and and she didn't
you know she got I don't want to say
sick but she had to you know talk to her
mom and stuff a bunch after that I got a
Sandy hand job one time in Clearwater
Beach did you oh every hand job is
saying on there dude you can't keep sand
off your dick south of uh north of
Destiny just rubbing the skin off and
you just were like just it'll be over in
a second we just gotta get through this
this is the hard part this is love this
is mile 20 of the marathon here we go
here we go come on
dude yeah [__] yeah gotta miss those
days like when like you're when like you
were like you'd get so excited to touch
body and you'd be like oh my god oh yeah
I remember the first time I finger to
check I was like Wow secret time I saw
it I was in the haunted house ride at
Disney World in Orlando and it was the
part where like and I just I never
thought about it I never like I was in
eighth grade and I was like we're making
out on the ride and I'm playing with her
boob and then all of a sudden I just was
like let's see if this works and it just
went in so quick and like it just it
just worked it just went yeah and I was
like whoa and then I didn't know what to
do with my finger and I just left it
there like I was taking her temperature
yeah just left it in there like yeah
pretty nice huh that's a swaggy day
she's like huh I'm like yeah
that's an old doctor move dude dude bro
I remember one time I was in I was doing
a college show somewhere this is like 10
years ago and afterwards I was drinking
at a house on I was drinking at a house
right yeah I didn't know the house was
on campus but the police show up and
they say this house is technically on
campus it didn't look like it was on
campus at all it's like a regular house
yeah it was like a dormitory or like a
you know um a quadruplex or anything
like that
um
so the cops came took me to jail right
and there was this girl I was flirting
with and I was like excited maybe I get
to hook up well anyway I get back to the
hotel my buddies are staying in the
morning the girl slept over she hooked
up with my buddy right yeah and um
and he had broken both of us he had two
broken arms though so my other buddy had
to hold him up while he was [__] her
like he like he like laid on got on top
of her but then my other buddy was real
strong like Adonis like leaned over and
just held him up the whole time by his
chest so he could just like dangle his
arms like because my buddy was on top
like he could just dangle his arms and
still have sex and then me and the girl
ended up having sex dude and she had the
darkest Bush I've ever seen in my life
and it was like three or four inches
long and it was straight she was like
black she was African-American but just
kind of in the [__] and it was um just
the hair was just very you know it was
more of African type of hair you know
and it was just so exciting it was such
an exciting time and that was up in um
Binghamton I think I remember I remember
in uh my junior year high school yeah no
no it must have been sophomore year high
school where Ty Rodriguez's house and uh
and everyone's everyone's hooking up
like it was just a bunch of girls bunch
of guys it's just like you know it's
just like [__] like I think like what
do they call it like uh
make out Fest or something and then the
next morning we're all eating breakfast
and uh everyone was like did you hook up
I was like yeah I made out pretty
[__] aggressively with I'm just
saying a name like Jennifer and they're
like uh they're like really and my buddy
Shawn hooker goes at what time
probably like night time one and he goes
you think it was one more round two I
said well I don't know it was right
before we all went to bed and they
started laughing I go why and he goes
because she would sucked my dick at
midnight then I was like
and that's when everyone's like so wait
what's hookers dictate I shouldn't say
his name I guess [__] what's
hookers yeah
he knows man but yeah those [__]
times you're like oh God this is gonna
make me into a comedian I guess I could
have a sense of humor about that [__]
I've never been a cool dude with chicks
I wish really never never I could never
turn it off but D oh I could see that I
was always trying to be funny even when
we got back to the room I just couldn't
turn it off really yeah I get
uncomfortable and then like leaning in
for a first kiss oh dude that's like
it's almost like talking a different
language for me like to be able to like
go from what this is right here like
this energy right here which will work
this works with a chick like hanging out
making her laugh get back to the room
and then going from this to yeah slow
dude remember how whenever you were
young what face is this oh yeah okay
yeah that's crazy it's like kissing a
[__] lizard and I kiss with my eyes
open oh really yeah that's insane scared
the [__] out of some chicks before
and then they open their eyes like what
the [__] and you're like what what dude
that heat Rhyme or oh I remember we
played spin the bottle at this party and
like the prettiest girl in our town dude
this girl had the big I was in love with
this girl her name was Emily Baumgartner
and she was gonna kiss me and I could
just I got this weird feeling at first I
thought that she had to vomit and I had
to vomit at the same time I didn't know
what the feeling was right but later on
in life I realized that means we kind of
were into each other because I was like
I love that your first kiss
it is so weird like a yeah that was just
and then you're like oh now I'm getting
sick like oh my God Theo that's [__]
brilliant the oh my God that's so
[__] brilliant she goes in to kiss
you but it does look like you're about
to be sick like she's like
and then you're like oh I think I'm
gonna throw up now oh do you want to get
a bucket oh my God because if I see
someone throw up I throw up
and then we just put each other's mouths
in the [__] forces Cloud but no I
what for me it was there was something
going on between us and she liked me
yeah and I thought whenever like we
looked at each other we there was this
weird feeling and that's when I thought
we're both gonna vomit like I was like
oh something does she have to vomit
maybe I some you know it's just
uncomfortable but then it was time to
kiss like the bottle spawn or whatever
and then I was like holy [__] don't
wanna [__] kiss like the girl in my
dreams and I didn't know how to kiss
anybody dude and as I got closer to her
my mouth kept opening wider and wider
because I've seen something on
television right
yeah and then I literally just wrapped
my whole [__] mouth like around her
kind of mouth and chin and somebody
laughed dude some little [__] imp
some little [__] Mulan Bluebird what
would you rather have you ready yeah
what would you rather have I'd rather
that she had an Instagram so that I
could see her once in a while because
she doesn't she doesn't there's no
pictures she could be deceased and if
she is I'm really sorry to her family
but I've never seen any pictures of her
online I've looked everywhere I looked
for the black kid in my neighborhood
last night did you yeah I looked for him
I think I found him he's front we have
two mutual friends but and I think that
that and then he lives in Tampa if I was
looking for him last night I just woke
up had a dream about him and his sister
and uh and I and I looked him up and I
think I got him his dad's on there but
his mom's not on there and so I'm like
his mom might have passed but uh what
would you rather have
uh there's no question for me
to go back in time and re-experience
your first kiss or go back in time and
it re-experienced the first time you had
sex with someone
first kiss yeah [__] first sex first
kiss Marie Koval seventh grade
we were up in my bedroom our parents
were downstairs having like a dinner
party and we were just messing around
and I was on my back and she was on her
back we were listening to music and she
just rolled over rolled over I think we
were head to head just rolled over
leaned over and started kissing me like
upside down and I just do my tits got
loose like just shaking I lost my
stomach and then I was like and then I
heard my sister Bert mom and dad want
you and Marie to come downstairs and I'm
like oh
dude I and by the way I kissed her
probably like four times and every
single time
felt like a first kiss yeah
oh
dude I remember there was this girl
named Chrissy hunt when I was real young
and she could have been seven or she
could have been [__] 40.
and she um the first time we kissed I
think she had blood in her mouth for
some reason and it was uh because her
teeth were all banged up I don't know
what happened she may have been in a
wreck right before we kissed and uh but
she had blood in her mouth and I
remember thinking that was crazy and
then years later
um but I remember oh the kids and
neighborhood kids would lock us in a
room together and we weren't allowed to
come out until we kissed and it was just
the hardest [__] thing in the world
bro it was like I was just because I
knew we both knew we had to and I had to
do something I was supposed to like be
the man you know but I couldn't be the
man yeah and I'm in the room and all I
want to do is kiss her dude and I'd
usually been humping my pillow at night
and my buddy would come over and we
would practice humping our pills one
other side of a whistle and blow it on
the other one if he was doing like bad
moves on the pillow yeah way too hard
kind of Raby back off back there you go
pick it up neutral Corners neutral
corners of the bed
there you go up under up under oh
feathers feathers feathers feathers
you're [__] the feathers
but it was fun bro and then I remember
in uh junior high school finally I got
to
daddy girl and she looked just like a
boy everybody thought that she was a boy
and uh we would kiss like at the school
bus would come but it would come from
the older school where all the older
kids were yeah and me and her would be
standing there like waiting to kiss
every time we would always just end up
hugging and then somebody yelled out one
time just kiss each other you [__]
and use the n-word ass dude right and we
were both white and we're like [__] we
gotta do it now you know what I'm saying
like people are getting us racially
confused they're starting to hate us so
much
I just started making out
so dude it's just crazy the power of
racism dude
bro and then I'm making out with this
girl that looks like
a boy
I dated her for four years then we dated
for like a year and she always wanted
like base all clothes and stuff for like
all like the dances and all like dances
she wanted us to wear like baseball [__]
oh I went through a Tara lesbians like
that I went through a tear of them I
could see that I had a period where I
was I would date a girl and then
immediately they'd come out gay and I'd
be like God damn it is it me it's not me
I think there I was just that that was
the first step that was the I was the
least threatening of what they were
looking for you're like John Levitz in A
League of Their Own just every time he
goes to he just pulls the lesbian out up
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one